[Müzik]
[Alkış]
tarihte bir ilk hocam bir yere gitmesin
diye Ben getirdim hocamı her şey yolunda
Evet daha önce bir prova yaptık da o
yüzden birkaç kişi peşimde dolanıyor
sağa sola gitmeyeyim
diye Öncelikle ev sahibi sayılırım O
yüzden Hoş geldiniz diyorum e üye
misafirlerimize genelde ikinci bir
soruyu soruyoruz üzülerek Eee kapıdan
kolay girdiniz mi ya Çünkü kapıda bazen
olayı çok ciddiye alıyorlar od diye
Sınavla girilir falan diye O yüzden
kusura bakmayın ama standart soru
bu insanların çoğuna güneşle ilgili ne
düşünüyorsunuz Diye sorduğumuzda bir
duyguları var severiz sevmeyiz bir bir
duyguları var fakat ayla ilgili çoğu
insanda ne bir Empati ne bir sempati
kısaca apati diyebileceğim bir
ilgisizlik var niye Diye sorduğumuzda
Yani herhangi bir faydasını görmedik
diyorlar Tamam orada birkaç tırnak
içinde sersem romantik hariç kimsenin
Ayla ilgilendiği yok fakat durum öyle mi
Bakın size bugün biraz onu anlatacağım
Dünya ile
ay güzel bir dans içindeler yavaş ve
güzel bir dans içindeler Ama bu her
zaman böyle
değildi ayın dikkat ettiniz mi
bilmiyorum arka yüzünü hiç görmedik Biz
ayın bir günü yani kendi eks etrafında
bir tur atışı tam 7 gün yani bir ay Biz
ayın sadece Ön yüzünü görebiliyoruz arka
yüzünü ilk defa 59'da Sovyetler Birliği
Eee Bir uzay aracı göndermiş fotoğrafını
çekmişti çok enteresan Tabii bu her
zaman böyle değildi Eee ay ilk
oluştuğunda dünyaya çok yakındı
milyarlarca yıl önce Dünyanın kendi
ekseni etrafında dönüşü yaklaşık 5,5 6
saatti
ayda birkaç bin kilometre ötede O da çok
hızlı dönüyordu ve müthiş bir e zorlu
bir dans vardı aslında Ay bir anlamda
bizim okyanusumu çalmak istiyordu her
gün 3 saat
aralıklarla okyanusları birkaç yüz
kilometre kıyıya çekiyor tekrar geriye
doğru bırakıyordu müthiş gelgitler vardı
Yani tabii ki E çok büyük bir ihtimalle
bu gelgitler birkaç yüz kilometre kıyıya
doğru gelen sular içeriye doğru
mineralleri götürdü Ve okyanuslarda
hayatın başlaması için çok önemli bir
rol oynadı 1000 yıl civarında
Eee ay ayın kendi Eksen etrafında dönüşü
durdu dünyanın ay üstünde gösterdiği
gelgit Kuvvetleri ayı Esasen Eee kendi
ekseni etrafında dönmesini yavaşlattı
Dünyanın kendi ekseni etrafında
de her gün yavaşlıyor geceler de uzuyor
gündüzler de uzuyor yani çok az ama
dinozorlar yeryüzündeyken bir gün
yaklaşık 23 saatti ve eğer bakacak
olursanız Eee çok uzun bir süre sonra
Dünyanın kendi ekseni etrafında dönüşü
tam 47 gün olacak ayın da 47 gün
dünyanın da 47 gün olacak yani ayile
olan bu dansımız çok ilginç hayatla
başladı ve bir süre sonra kilitlenecek
ve Eee
Esasen direkt doğrudan doğruya
senkronize bir şekilde devam edeceğiz
şimdi bunu nereden biliyoruz birincisi
fiziğin denklemlerinden biliyoruz
İkincisi de Esasen başka gezegenleri
inceleyebilir oradan
biliyoruz haley hale deniyordu Osmanlı
zamanında 1665 yılında şunu fark etti 9
asırda rakka'da Halep'te yaşamış bugün
Çok vahim topraklarda yaşamış el
battaninin tuttuğu ayla ilgili defterler
hesaplar
ile el battani Yaklaşık 700 yıl önce
yaşamış batlamyus'un tuttukları arasında
fark var incelediğinde y ne farkı var
mesela Güneş tutulmasına bakıyor çok
hassas bir kısım farklılıklar var saniye
dakika farklılıkları ve şu oradan şunu
çıkarıyor diyor ki
ay Muhtemelen
ivmelenmek ivmelenir Çünkü bir
farklılıklar var hatta 1665 yılında
yazdığı bu makaleye baktığınızda
gerçekten hayranlık duyuyorsunuz bunları
tespit edebilmek için Halep'in rakka'nın
yerlerini detaylı bir şekilde incelemiş
yaklaşık 45 dilde yazılmış bir bir
makale çok ilginç daha sonra tabii ki
Eee halley'in ulaştığı Eee son sonucun
yanlış olduğunu biliyoruz Ay
ivmelenmiyor Güneş Esasen dünya Esasen
güneşin kendi ekseni etrafında dönüşünü
azaltıyor ayın gelgitleri nedeniyle bunu
da Charles Darwin'in oğlu
e mekaniği kullanarak
okyanusların her seferinde geriye
çekilip tekrar kıyıya vurduğunda
sürtünmeyle dünyayı Esasen
yavaşlattığını keşfediyor gelgitlerle
aynı zamanda ayı da her sene 3.8 cim
parmağınıza bakın 3.8 cim bizden
uzaklaştırıyor Yani bir süre sonra Ay
bayağı bir uzaklaşmış olacak Dünyanın
kendi ekseni etrafında dönüşü 47 gün
ayın kendi bizim etrafımızda dönüşü 47
gün ve kendi ekseni etrafında dönüşü de
47 gün
olacak Eskiden gelgitler böyleydi Tabii
ki bunu Yıldızlar Arası film filmden
aldım orada da müthiş gelgitler vardı
gelgiti hesap edemeden oraya gittiler
şimdi bu iyi mi kötü mü bu benim oğlum
Hüseyin çın
H Çınar iin İyi hem Geceler uzuyor hem
gündüzler uzuyor ileride 20 yaşına
geldiğinde şimdi 20 aylık mervelere
gittiğinde ders çalışmak için daha uzun
süre kalabilecek şanslı Şimdi ben size
niye bunu
anlatıyorum şimdi ekşi sözlükte 2004
yılında Birisi demiş ki açılan her
muhabbeti sonunda muhakkak surle kar
dilik
Bağlar Kara deliklere bağ dediği bu
bağlayacak mıy bağlamak mıyım Görece bir
sebebi var bakın 9194 arasında ORT Doğu
Teknik üniversitesi'de fizik
okudum Bu benim mezuniyetim cübbesiz
gördüğünüz kişi benim
e tek fotoğrafım bu üde okurken tek
fotoğrafım bu Bunu da birkaç ay önce
bana gönderdiler biraz protesto modunda
olduğumu görebiliyorsunuz Değil mi
cübbem yok diplomam var gösterebilirim
Bakın ben ders
alırken
bir defa müthiş bir azimle buraya
gelmiştim eski matematikçilerin hayatını
okumuştum idealism sadece fizik okumak
istiyordum kız arkadaşım yoktu kayıtlara
geçsin Erkek arkadaşım da yoktu hiçbir
şeyle ilgilenmiyordu sadece tek
ilgilendiğim şey fizik fakat 1982
Anayasası ile birlikte Türkçe dersleri
ve tarih dersleri zorunlu olarak
verilmişti ya ben de hani Türkçede bütün
soruları yapıp girmiş bir insan olarak
bunu bir protesto edeyim dedim Türkçe
dersinde Mimarlık bölümünde alıyorum
keyifle alıyorum Türkçe dersinde Hocamız
dedi ki Nazım Hikmet'in havan röportajı
şiirini okuyun ve bir kompozisyon yazın
ben de Havan röportajı şiirini okudum
Gerçekten çok güzel bir şiir yani
mükemmel bir şiir ve şöyle yazmaya
başladım Nazım Hikmet'in bu şiiri
muhteşemdir Nazım Türkçe'nin büyük bir
şairidir Eee keyifle okudum vesaire ama
Nazım Hikmet Eğer kozmoloji ile
ilgileneyim
kozmoloji evrenin müthiş bir şiiridir
çok detaylı bir şiiridir
ve matematiğin sonsuz rafine diliyle
yazılmıştır Nazim de buna bayılırdı
şöyleydi böyleydi kozmoloji 1 bu5 ik
sayfa kozmoloji hocamız tuttu getirdi ön
Sırada oturuyorum dedi ki senin
Muhtemelen fizik derslerin de kötüdür
Türkçen çok kötü dedi Dedim ki hocam
biraz hafif karizmam çizildiği için
hocam dedim ben bölümüm birincisiyim
olamaz dedi gidip hocalar la konuşacağım
Neyi konuşacaksınız yani böyle bir tepki
yok tabii hani tam olarak neyi konuşmayı
düşünüyorsunuz daha sonra daha sonra
tarih bölümün tarih dersinde benzeri bir
tepkiyi verdim O biraz daha ağırdı Şimdi
burada anlatamayacağım ne oldu biliyor
musunuz tarihten kaldım 3 yıllık ODTÜ
eğitim hayatım boyunca 2 sene tarih
dersi almak zorunda kaldım 20 yıllık
öğrenciliğim de tek tekrar ettiğim ders
Tarih dersidir O da kredisiz bir ders
Titreye titreye geçtim Sonra dedim ki
bütün dersleri Ben mi protesto edeceğim
derslere gitmemeye başladım ve kendi
bölümümü birincisi olarak mezun oldum
şimdi bakın Einstein denklemi bu sonsuz
bir edebiyat hiçbir zaman sonsuz
edebiyatı bu kadar küçük bir yere
sığdıramazsın ben buna lineer olmayan
edebiyat diyorum niye biliyor musunuz
burada Sonsuz tane cümle var Esasen ve
biz bu cümleleri bulmaya çalışıyoruz
Einstein'ın 1916'da ki denklemi
insanlara anlatmaya çalıştığım Bu bir
tane denklem var sanki bir tane çözümü
var diyeceksiniz Hayır sonsuz tane
çözümü var ve evrenin dinamiğini veriyor
evrenle ilgili evrenle ilgili zamanla
ilgili evrenin geçmişi ile ilgili her
şeyi bu söylüyor şiir bir şeyleri
saklamaya çalışır kozmoloji açıklamaya
çalışır rüşte hocam biraz sonra
konuşacak kusura bakmasın şiiri de
seviyorum Şimdi Bakın ben niye konuyla
bu şekilde ilgileniyorum Organize İşler
diye bir film var belki görmüşsünüzdür
başında sonunda ne oluyor Hiç umrumda
değil hatırlamıyorum bile ama bir sahne
var ki beni çok etkiliyor Neden dayak
yemişler Belli ki ahırda dayak yemiş bu
kişiler ve aralarında diyorlar ki ya
İnsan insanı bu kadar döver mi yani
dövdüler bayıltıyorlar ayılıp tekrar
dövüyorlar ve Felsefi bir şekilde dayağı
anlamaya çalışıyorlar yani Dayak nedir
Hani niye bu kadar dayak yiyoruz
kendilerini döven Müslüm Cem Yılmaz
diyor ki siz şimdi aranızda
konuşuyorsunuz ve düşünüyorsunuz Dayak
nedir ve Neden atılır benim beni
etkilemesinin sebebi bu sabah kalktığım
zaman nedir ve neden böyledir
düşünceleriyle Sürekli etrafı evreni ve
insanları Esasen anlamaya çalışıyorum
Bakın bu çok önemli 500 yıl önce büyük
bir devrim oldu aslında buralara çok
fazla gelmedi daha Ama getirmeye
çalışıyoruz Bu Devrim bilimsel düşünce
bilimsel düşünme
devrimiyle anlamaya çalışıyorlardı
bakalım evrene ve teori oluşturalım Ama
hiçbir şekilde görüntü Bizi
ilgilendirmesi görüntüdeki bütün
bozukluklar saçmalıktır bunun arkasında
bir gerçek var vardır diye mesela Aristo
için Derler ki hayatı boyunca kadınların
ağzında erkeklere göre daha az diş
sayısı vardı hayatı boyunca buna inandı
iki sefer evlenmiş olmasına rağmen
eşlerinin dişlerini saymadı küçük bir
projeyle sayabilir de Esasen Ama buna
inandı Çünkü görüntü Onu
ilgilendirmiyordu daha sonra deney ve
gözlem ortaya çıktı
brahe benden tam Ben Doğmadan 400 yıl
önce yani
1572 gökyüzünü 26 yaşında incelerken Ken
çok parlak bir şey gördü Gökyüzünde bir
değişiklik beklemiyorlardı brah 16 ay
boyunca bugün supernova dediğimiz parlak
bir ışığı takip etti ve ardından gözlem
ortaya çıktı gözlemeli bakmalısınız
görüntü önemli görünüş önemli Yani illa
bunları unutalım onun arkasında bir
gerçek var Onu bulalım eflatun'un
hikayeleri gibi değil ve deneysel ve
gözlemsel bilim başladı ve bunların
içerisinde Galileo Galilei çok önemli Az
önce Hüseyin Çınar'ı gördünüz bakın
doğduğunda Hüseyin Çınar'ın adını
Hüseyin Galileo Çınar koyacaktım ilk
önce kim karşı çıktı Biliyor musunuz
annesi burada 3ün koltukta oturuyor önce
annesi Karşı Çıktı bütün cesaretle
Çankaya nüfus müdürlüğüne gittim Galileo
diyecektim son anda vazgeçtim Vazgeçtim
Halbuki Galileo ile Celil kelimesi aynı
kelimeler Esasen Galileo Celil geliyor
incelerseniz bulursunuz Siz Eğer şeyi
anlatamam
Galileo herhalde herhalde herhalde
herhalde şimdi bakın Galileo bırakın
evreni bırakın evreni böyle birden bütün
anlamayı bu evrenle ilgili küçük bir
gerçeği öğreneyim bana yeter dedi bakın
çok önemli çok önemli Galileo dan
öncekiler Aman oturayım böyle düşüneyim
de evrenle ilgili bir şeyler bulayım
görüntüyle ilgilenmeye diyorlardı
Galileo dedi ki şu yere attığımız
taşlara bakalım yere atılan taşların
tamamı büyüklüklerinde ağırlıklarından
kompozisyonların bağımsız olarak aynı
ivmeyle yere düşerler atmosferi
düşünmezsen yere ne atarsanız atın aynı
şekilde yere düşer Galileo gravitasyon
kütle çekiminin çok farkında değildi ama
bu gerçek bu gerçek ne zaman açıklandı
biliyor musunuz niye yere atılan her şey
aynı ivmeyle yere düşer 274 yıl sonra
Albert Einstein Bunu niye böyle olduğunu
açıkladı ve ilk defa zamanın teorisini
evrenin teorisini verdi bakın küçük bir
gerçek inanılmaz derecede büyük bir
sonuca büyük bir teoriye yol açtı küçük
Gerçekler Çok önemli burada güzel bir
şey var Galileo da komputer bilgisayar
olsaydı bilgisayarları atacaktı Çünkü
Onun derdi Onu
öğrenmekti ilk bilimsel dergi 1665
yılında yayınlanmaya başladı internette
var gidip okuyabilirsiniz inanılmaz
derecede güzel Mesela size bir örnek
vereyim 1665 yılında Türkiye ile ilgili
bir makale var Türkiye diyor Esasen bu
makalenin orijinaldir inquiry for Turkey
Türkiye ile ilgili sorular İçinde 23
maddede sorular var aslında Yaklaşık 100
tane soru var bakın Ne kadar detaylı bir
şekilde evren ve etrafla ilgilenmeye
başlamışlar soru 1 Türkler rusma diye
bir tüy dökücü kullanıyorlar rusma
nerede bulunur Başka ne için kullanı be
adam derdin rusma nedir ya rusma tüy yol
ucu nedir öyle değil Rus Man'ın ne
olduğunu öğrenmek istiyorlar ve nerede
İkinci soru Türkler afyon'u neden
kullanıyorlar atlarına da veriyorlar mı
en yüksek dozda afyon'u Hangi insan
almış kahveyi niçin içiyorlar niye banyo
yapıyorlar Saçlarını niye tıraş
ediyorlar pirinç niye yiyorlar mükemmel
atları nasıl yetiştiriyorlar İstanbul'da
eski büyük depremler var mı bakın
İstanbul'da eski büyük depremler var mı
su kanalların içindeki kullandıkları
alçılar eskilerin romalıların
kullandıkları kadar güzel mi muhteşem
Süleyman'ın yaptığı su kanalları nasıl
en son soru cahiller o eski yaptığı
yapılan muhteşem eserleri koruyorlar mı
sorulara bakın müthiş göreceksiniz ki ne
kadar detayı bir şekilde etrafla
ilgileniyorlar Çünkü bir bilimsel Devrim
olmuştu etrafı inceleyelim bana
gelgitlerle ilgili Konuş deyince ben
direkt olarak Bunu düşündüm gelgit
mekanizması nedir önce bunu anlayayım
Çünkü karşı gelebilmek için anlamak
gerekiyor Belki de belki de karşı da
gelemeyecek anlamayın Belki de karşı da
gelmek gerekmiyor anlayalım Yeter ki
anlayalım
gelgitler bakın çok önemli bir şey
var güneşin Dünya üstünde oluşturduğu
kuvvet ayile kıyaslandığında 180 kat
daha fazla ama güneşin dünya üstündeki
etkisi ayın etkisinin
yarısından daha az direkt Albert
Einstein'ın teorisiyle uyumlu yani
güneşin gelgitler üstündeki etkisi bütün
gelgitlerin % 30'u yken ayın % 70 180
kat daha fazla olmasına rağmen güneşin
etrafında dönüyoruz ama ay ayın çekimi
bizi daha fazla etkiliyor burada önemli
bir nokta Kuvvetin büyüklüğü değil
kuvvetin farklılığı Güneş O kadar uzak
ki dünyanın üstünde her yerde hemen
hemen aynı kuvveti oluşturuyor güneşin
kütle çekimini tespit etmek ayini tespit
etmeye göre daha zor birincisi bu
gelgitler mekanizmasında ikincisi de şu
gelgit olabilmesi için ik tane zıt
yönünde kuvvet olması lazım Ay bizim
okyanusumu çalmaya Çalışıyor yani
abartarak söylüyorum bilerek yaptığı bir
şey değil ama biz de vermek istemiyoruz
geriye doğru çekiyoruz bütün bu
sürtünmeye neden oluyor tamam mı iki
kuvvet olması lazım şimdi başka
mekanizmalar var burada ama ben şunu
düşündüm bu iki mekanizmayla gelgitleri
incelesin Bunlar acaba yaşadığımız
gelgitlerin nedeni olabilir mi Bir de
Tsunamiler var içten gelen onlar çok
büyük dalgalar okyanusun tabanı birden
çöküyor ve bütün Okyanus bir bir Esasen
nehir gibi nehir gibi kıyıya doğru
gidiyor ve bu 2004 yılındaki Eee Hint
okyanusundaki Tsunami 300.000 kişiyi
öldürmüştü tsunaminin de fiziği
çalışılmış durumda 1800'lerin başında
fark ediliyor normal bir dalga değil
soliton dediğimiz çok enteresan bir
dalga enerjisini kaybetmeden binlerce
kilometre
gidebiliyor içten gelen şeyler de çok
önemli Belki de içeriden g gelen bir
kısım sıkıntıları yaşıyoruz bu bölgenin
ben
bir Tsunami yaşadığını düşünüyorum İşin
açıkçası
toplumu ileriye götürmeye çalışan
kuvvetler genelde sayıca Çok az Ama
bunlar çok önemli bakın tren örneği çok
sıradan bir örnek ama söylemek
istediğimi ifade ediyor sadece bir tane
lokomotif toplumu ileriye doğru çekmek
istiyor bir sürü kendisini takip eden
vagonları ileriye doğru çekiyor Esasen
Sağlı bir toplumda ileriye geriye
kuvvetler belli bir denge içerisinde
devam
ediyorlar gelgitlerin Belki de temel
mekanizması bu bunu anlamak gerekiyor
ileriye doğru çeken kuvvetlere yardımcı
olmak
gerekiyor anlamak en büyük silahımız
Esasen Belki de bakın burada Hawking
kara deliklerle bitirmeye belki dedim
ama bitireceğim mecburen Hawking bir
Anladığım kadarıyla belediyye
başkanlığına aday olmuş birisi davet
ediyor diyor ki kel son hak karadelikler
bahsediyor karadeliğe girdikten sonra
çıkmamız imkansız diyor ki engelli
kardeşimiz karadeliklere giriş
çıkışlarda problem olduğunu söylüyor
böyle bir belediyecilik olmaz hakim de
diyor ki konferans diye çağırdınız ne
yap ne yapıyorsunuz İndirin beni buradan
O da diyor ki yere gitme bırakmam
teşekkür
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
ederim
y